[Music]
today's question comes from laura in
florida i am studying interior design
and i have been doing some work for free
for a friend who is already a designer
to get experience recently she asked me
to take on some time intensive projects
i would like to be paid for these
projects but am unsure how to ask since
i have been doing other work for free
how do i ask to be paid for these larger
projects
well the simple answer is clearly and
nicely right with a with a good helping
of humility here the challenge is is uh
uh you started out working for free
which i want to first say dave a lot of
people
uh in today's environment and i'm not
gonna go on a rant here but they they
just look down their nose at
getting themselves in by working for
free and it's all about i deserve the
dignity being paid and this is the way
the world works so i applaud laura for
getting in and doing some work for free
but now the friend who has said okay
we've got some new projects um i think
you have to sit down and go hey
i'm so grateful that you allowed me this
opportunity
always gratitude always lead with
grateful for this uh it has been
invaluable to me these projects seem to
be
a lot more time intensive and because of
that i'm wondering can you pay and what
could you pay me for these because this
is going to eat into the other areas of
your life and this is what i mean by
clearly don't speak in gray black and
white so that and don't your friends
understand
around the edges
touch
here's how it's going to affect my life
for these time intensive projects could
you pay me notice how i'm stating this
could you pay me and what would you be
willing to pay me and we have a
conversation not a negotiation this is a
friend who's already done you a real
solid and i think if you go that
direction and that kind of posture and
when i say posture i i don't mean the
physical posture i mean the emotional i
think if you do it the right way
your friend's gonna let you know what
she can or can't do and then you have to
be a big girl
and decide what you can and can do
here's the thing anytime
any of us
are in a conversation with someone
that is uncomfortable or awkward
we tend
to in the name of being nice
do a ballroom dance
all around the issue
instead of just saying what it is that's
right it is a lot less painful
and kinder
to be just cut straight through it and
very calm
lower your voice tone your volume
everything and just say
what it is
uh i mean whatever the situation is just
say it yeah and it takes the air out of
the room and and
otherwise all this ballroom dancing adds
to the awkwardness
and i did this and and you guys would
think well dave's always blunt well you
know what i've gotten more blunt i've
gotten more direct because of this idea
and because early on in our career you
know we had folks working on the team we
had maybe a team of 20 people or
something like that someone would be
screwing around they wouldn't be doing
their work they'd be off track or they
weren't good at it or whatever and i
would get continually frustrated and
they never knew it
because in the name of being nice
i never told them that they sucked at
what they were doing right and it wasn't
nice
because i got more and more and more
frustrated until finally then then i
would there would be a i wasn't ever
mean to somebody but that would be like
this one little thing and i would hit
i'd hit this little number one with a
10.
and and they're going where'd that come
from well it came from six months of me
putting up with you not doing it and and
but i never said anything because i was
nice that's the key and that's just bs
to be unclear is to be unkind
and here's the deal if we don't fill in
the blanks for people they'll fill them
in for us
and they're there therein lies the
frustration well are you talking about
dance they're gonna think it's worse
than it is
but
that's the other thing they're trying to
read your mind
you're trying to read theirs and it just
gets into this weird thing versus this
is a friend this is an easy conversation
i know
where laura's coming from it feels like
they're going to re-frame this just
reframe it all it is is you did some
part-time work for free yeah and it's
over that's it yeah
it's hard oh and there's another chance
here to do some more work but it's not
going to be free that's right you just
need to go thanks for all the thanks for
letting me come in here and learn this
stuff and hey i'm not going to be able
to work on this to other stuff unless
there's pay involved because it's it's
just too much and but thanks so much for
letting me do this lead with gratitude
close with gratitude
make a gratitude sandwich man i mean by
the way the backside of this folks if
laura goes in with that posture and
she's been tremendously valuable to her
friend and her friend realizes she's not
working for free anymore great chance
that she scraps some money together to
hire laura so going in free and adding
tremendous value you never know what
that could lead to i'll give you a 50 50
chance of almost thinking about paying
her anyway i think so i mean you know
she's actually she you know unless she's
just trying to take advantage of